now that's the ideological side of
things how about the practical side of
things or these riots still gonna keep
burning you know they're making up an
invisible villains and invisible enemies
at a certain point you think that would
burn out the be haz the Black House
autonomous zone in DC is still running
but the Capitol Hill autonomous zone in
Seattle it is no more the dream of Chaz
chop is over a statement from the Chaz
Chad Twitter account says quote few
people remain in our beloved chop the
statement was signed by the capitol hill
occupied protest solidarity committee
and they said very finely the chop
project is now concluded
no more chop it's very sad but that's
just the way that it goes
it was always ever it was as always ever
thus right it was always going to go
away
it was a utopian project and like all
utopian projects it was disgusting it
was terrible it was violent people died
it destroyed property it destroyed the
rights of certain people yet the mayor
of Seattle who was tolerating this said
it was going to be the Summer of Love
I didn't look very much like the Summer
of Love now the Summer of Love has
fizzled out I think it went so quickly
because we're just moving on a faster
timeline here we're moving on a faster
news cycle we're moving on a faster
protest cycle we went from tearing down
robert e lee to tearing down statues of
saint Junipero Serra very quickly right
it began to tearing down any depiction
of Jesus that looks white according to
Sean King things are getting a little
bit faster and the bright side of that
is things like the Chazz will fizzle out
[Music]
[Music]